[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're going to love it here
greatest city in the world nor the next
chapter in its long history of greatness
[Music]
so wonderful to welcome the brand to the
Lakers family we're definitely going to
the tournament this year they've better
[Applause]
go back to Cleveland we don't want you
[Music]
nights of house Lakers tonight we
commence what is sure to be a glorious
season the beginning of the end of the
long drought for the king of the east
now Don's the purple and gold and
together we will restore the glory of
the greatest house in the Western realm
now please eat
especially you Ingram no burner you go
pestle bran first now oh sorry
you must have burned your tongue your
breath so I hear you're to be involved
in the production of CGM - is that
correct yes that's right Oh delightful
well I was thinking if you're looking to
say reprise Shawn Bradley's character
I'm a very accomplished actor actor
editions prohibitions an annoying sect
of extremist Kobe family this is done by
Lakers fan Lang sir not lik affirms the
Kobe fans they don't accept LeBron they
think he's a soft [ __ ] you can't play
defense I'm Brandon well that's what
they say alright let me talk to them
don't bother LeBron you can reason with
them just ignore him
if I could win back the families of
Cleveland I can certainly win the hearts
of a few crazy Kobe fan links good
people of Los Angeles give my chance
give him a chance like you I have much
respect for Kobe cuz he's the GU never
be Kobe brother I'm not trying to be
well you should yeah he's better than
you okay well is there anything I could
possibly do to win you over
gave us a billion go what else Kobe
tattooed on his head definitely no
hunter championship
yes okay you got winner six
championships salmon what you realize
cool be only one five yeah but he's a
closer [ __ ] finishes ice I finish
according to the analytics maesters I'm
actually more clutch than Kobe nah
Kobe's a killer like a mum bass well I
built a school Wow
oh you built a school yeah that's cuz
you're soft yeah you have nothing to
prove to these fools they're just a few
nuts living in their parents bonds
they'll come around believe real Kobe
fans will never accept the Frog he
doesn't have the Mamba mentality Toby
never missed a game winner I have
dedicated my life to the worship of
clovie and I would rather die than
worship the broad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you